do your issues with tammy all come down
to how much money you give your mom
so
i think
tammy just doesn't like what oswego
gives because tammy has given a lot of
money in the past i think now that
oswego is in america she's kind of
trying to pass that off on to him you
said a lot of money how how much is a
lot i mean i don't think oswell would
have survived growing up without her
money like he basically lived off of
tammy's money when he was in samoa wow
okay
and so what tammy feels that asuelu
needs to give to pay it back to pay it
back basically yep
[Music]
asuelu how much money do you think you
have given your mom i would say it's
like a lot because i
work before i came here so
i usually
give her my whole check when i starting
work probably like six to seven hundred
dollars a month
six to seven hundred dollars a month for
how long
what two or two years when we were
together
did you do it before me too or
yep so you've given your mother
thousands and thousands of dollars
yeah okay yeah i'm trying to do the
calculation i think it's almost
fifteen thousand dollars
and then even before he came to america
he cleaned out his whole bank account
and also gave that to her
which we fought over because i thought
that he should have brought it
to the babies or it was just oliver at
the time
and so you're feeling wow could have
paid a lot of bills
in your household mm-hmm
why do you think she
keeps asking you for money it's just how
like how so there in like life there the
culture here in the culture too like
when we success in life we need to like
taking care of our parents and our
family
it's also bingo money though
it's also bingo money
really
bingo money church fundraisers church
events
[Music]